e
l'an dernier pour avoir si on en
acheter un des mois et des mois
d'attente, c'est impossible à
de et c'est un
phénomène qui malheureusement
prend de l'ampleur
Les Québécois font plus de vélo
♪ ♪ ♪
- Un nouveau vélo qui aurait dû
elle a dû acheter
à contrecoeur.
DENISE SURPRENANT,
- J'étais prête à partir,
j'arrive ici, puis mon vélo qui,
habituellement il est en-dessou.
- Bien des cyclistes vivent
avec la crainte d'être victimes
de vol, et pour cause.
Environ 2000 vélos sont déclarés
volés auprès SPVM tous les ans.
selon Vélo Québec,
qui évalue à plus de 60 000
le nombre de vélos disparus
MAGALI BEBRONNE, directrice des
es, Vélo Québec
- On a coutume de dire que sur
10 cyclistes qui se feront vix
renoncera carrément à serachetea
de faire du vélo.
C'est vraiment regrettable.er
les bicyclettes démontées
en pleine rue.
certainement, des roues volées.
- Ce marchand de vélo en sait
quelque chose. Les pièces se
font si rares que leur prix
qu'ont flairée les voleurs.
ANDRÉ DESMEULES,
propriétaire, Vélomane
en plus de valeur à voler
quelque chose qui valait 20 $,$,
puis qui vaut 40 $, parce qu'on
voit des choses qui ont doublé.
volés sont retrouvés
par les policiers.
Cet homme a choisi de
se faire justice lui-même.
il retrouve son vélo sur
un site de revente dans
Son stratagème : il fait
une offre d'achat,
demande d'essayer le vélo,
puis décampe à toute vitesse
demeure confidentielle,
par crail point tu t'es dit c'et
la police qui va le retrouver?
- Nul, aucune chance d'après moi
que la p en mesure
de trouver un vélo volé.
reçoit maintenant des menaces.
STEVE GIRARD, commandant au
poste de quartier 44
- C'est pas une bonne idée.
qui se produisent lors des
achats et reventes et tout ç
Donc, de se faire justice
soi-même, c'est jamais
- Avant ça, ils rentraient
un outil ici, puis
réussissaient à ouvrir la porte.
- Dans cet immeuble à condos,
les vols à répétn.
- On a des caméras maintenant
qui permvoirvoirvoirvoirvoirvoir
tout l'ensemble du garage.
- Ils ont mis sur un pied
un systur piéger
les cambrioleurs.
evenant s'evenant s'evenant s'eé
à six reprises avant que
les policiers ne lui mettent
OLIVIER CÔTÉ, administrateur de
la page Vélos volés Montréal
- Fait que tu te dis que pourpee
que si on le fait pas, bien,ça .
- Pour protéger son nouvel
achat, Emmanuelle a opté pour
une solution qui permet
d'enregistrer son vélo
auprès du SPVM.
EMMANUELLE LAVOIE, cycliste
'est mon vélo,
on s'entraide.
te 44, une douzaine
de vélos ne pourront pas être
remis à leur propriétaire,
STEVE GIRARD, commandant au
poste de quartier 44
- Les vé
protection de Garage 529,
n'ont patte.
- Avec un peu plus de
7000 abonnés à Montréal,
elle aurait
e réduire e réduire e réduire es
de 40 % à Vancouver.
Ici Jean-Philippe Hughes,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.